but for ya feelin it you know what's up
what's up day after MLK Day what was it
this is so racist that it feels races
there but you got power yo but you know
it's [ __ ] urban Bobby in the house
now a raise the roof and all that it was
that dark right coolest kid
we got raise the roof I already said
that know what else you got who let the
dogs out to the left bro
yes to the left to the left
what about the right okay what's to the
right we don't know how we don't know
Beyonce was a Beyonce that's right I
even got that [ __ ] right to put my peeps
oh I'm okay in the anyway on what's up
welcome back
Tiger belly um yeah George George Kimmel
we got a Gilbert de londres well and
then we got um
kalila and we got white just white right
and then yeah but you know um I've been
trying to find trying to get Tiffany
Haddish because you know it's MLK just
listen it's MLK Day and we try to get
Tiffany Haddish and I couldn't get ahold
of her Leslie Jones is out of town I try
to get Ian Edwards on the line at night
yeah couldn't get any african-americans
so I uh I asked the closest thing that I
could find to that which is Dante Chang
[Applause]
you're the closest one thank you I knew
I knew that was the case cuz you called
me like 130 yeah yeah I was desperate
wrong though yeah I was just like who
who and the his his fat face entered my
mind I go Dante Chang let me tell you
something about this guy right here man
hmm you from DC correct yes sir
I you know here out of all the Asian
comedians he's the one that truly
follows the Korean culture to a tee he's
very respectful
he calls me hyung which is older brother
and he's always it's it just feels
respectful and I feel a sense of pride
when I'm with him you know I don't know
if he's Asian or black
I don't know Korean Korean but Jane's
Korean yes Korean my family's from North
India skip to China and I think what my
family's from North I've never met no on
[ __ ] door it's like meeting an
Eskimo coming next
wait you're your family's from what
family's up North Korea Wow
but they're like Mexicans do they
escaped here they escaped they're
defectors then we have my wife - my
wife's family - Wow
so you're with your grandparents yeah
grandparents they were different they
sound different - they don't sound like
regular Korean people like you know like
like I said give me an example like you
know he's like you said I say I'm gonna
have CEO in a regular Korean that's
similar but with the one that stands out
to most is what you know when you call
your parents you like you're like you're
like oh my like where they're like oh
mother wah wah Soviet twang to it yeah
yeah yeah yeah this is a slight
differences and people Korean people
they hear me talking so you say I'm most
Korean used to be great yeah yeah but
you don't sound Korean when you speak
English but that when does that when did
that happen I think I don't know just a
lot of smoking a lot of black influence
maybe yeah